Chloe Smith is with us the work and
pension secretary representing the
government this morning great to see you
thanks for joining us why is the pound
in free fall
well I won't be able to comment on on
Market movements and of course lots of
factors go into any particular market
movement but what I can say is that I
think we've been right to set out the
growth package that we did on Friday and
my particular interest in that of course
is helping more people into work and I
see a lot of opportunity in what the
chances are set out to help people get
their way into more opportunity and from
their greater Prosperity the government
must be alarmed though to see the
reaction from the markets well as I say
I'm not going to be able to comment on
particular Market movements and there
are various factors that always go into
those but the government is absolutely
focused on delivering the growth package
as we set out with various ways that
will be helping both businesses and
households to move ahead to growth and
as I say to Greater opportunity and for
me in particular from the work and
pensions Department I want to then be
able to help more people into more good
and well-paid jobs so you're not at all
concerned of what the parent's doing I'm
extremely focused on how to go for
growth and that is what the chancellor
set out and I think was right to do so
okay
um will we bring back the triple lock on
pensions
as you know uh in the previous period we
used a double log because of some of the
particular abnormalities that happened
during the coffee period And as you also
then know the government has confirmed
that we'll be returning to the triple
law it's definitely going to happen so
I'm looking forward to supporting
pensioners in that way and of course
that also comes on top of the part for
the pensioners of the cost of living
package that we have been rolling out in
recent months and are you going to
increase that is it 150 pounds at the
moment isn't it are you going to
increase that further we're continuing
to roll out that package and as you may
know we are ensuring that payments for
disabled people go out this particular
week that's one of my focuses this week
and pensioners as part of that package
uh have received support and I think
overall that's been a comprehensive
package the reason I ask is because I
had mencap on the show last week and
they said that that 150 pound payment
should be doubled
well I hear that argument but what I
would say is that the package overall
has been a comprehensive one and in
particular let's take the example of of
a household that might include a
disabled person if that's if that was
main Cap's argument well of course what
we've seen there is that at least 1200
pounds worth of support so that that
includes support on energy bills 400
pounds we've got all those figures
not enough and that includes a special
one 150 pound payment for disabled
people now in addition to that I would
then say you should look at the energy
price guarantee that we have since I
know all those figures we know all of
those figures no well if I make a these
are really important and my view is all
about them I'm putting to you that
mencap have said that they want that
number done yes indeed and I'm putting
to you that actually disabled people do
quite understandably have concerns about
energy for example if somebody uses
equipment in their home that takes more
energy to keep charged an entirely
understandable scenario and that's why
the government has acted in several ways
on energy and that's is why that's a
really important point so that's a no to
make to you okay are you going to
reinstate the 20 pound Universal Credit
uplift no we've been very clear that
that was a temporary uplift to do with
the pandemic and as I say since then we
have been also very very clear and I
would say comprehensive in the way that
we've supported people through the cost
of living okay but you are going to lift
the ban on Bankers bonuses but you're
not going to bring back the Universal
Credit we did the calculation on the
back of an envelope and apparently
someone earning a million pounds will
save 55 220 pounds a year uh under
quaten's budget that's not the bankers
bonuses that's just bringing down the
top rates of tax that equates to
53 years of 20 pounds Universal uplift
should you not look at that again well
first of all okay I'm delighted that
your figures are on the back of an
envelope that's reassuring to your your
viewers well I wonder how quick these
things are done but the key point is
this we have put forward measures that
do cut tax across a range of points
you're just going to ignore those
figures I'm going to tell you why we're
doing it which is the most important
point of all because a growth package is
designed to lead to jobs and jobs and
opportunity and the point I will be
prioritizing as work and pension
secretary is that growth and jobs are
one of the best ways for people to get
greater prosperity and that is why I
support a package that includes a
cutting corporation tax includes a cut
in income tax at various points of the
spectrum and The Cutting National
Insurance for both individuals and
businesses because that will put money
back into the coffers of thousands of
businesses and thousands of individual
household budgets so that they have an
opportunity to grow and choose how to
spend that okay let me go back with to
those figures 55 000 pounds profit for
it however you want to describe it but a
millionaire will have another 55 220
pounds next year as a result of cutting
the top rate of tax that's 53 years of
Universal Credit and yet you're saying
you don't want to reinstate the
Universal Credit
getting another point on the issue of
where to locate Financial Services jobs
I'm not sure we want those jobs to be in
this country to be in London or indeed
to be in Norwich my city or to be in
Edinburgh or to be in Belfast rather
than to be in Paris or New York and that
is the point as the chance to explain
very very clearly in fact I'm asking you
that behind that policy and that is why
I think that is a good policy because it
brings jobs to this country and
encourages uh that to be here now those
jobs are in turn very very important for
uh claimants of Universal Credit who I
want to see go into more work better
work and a great career that is the
absolute focus of my department so you
ask me what I would like to see for
Universal Credit claimants I'd like to
see greater opportunities more jobs
better jobs and that's why this growth
package has been the right one okay so
people can't expect an uplift in
Universal Credit even though Bank
millionaires can get an extra 55 grand
next year
you've asked me the question in a few
ways several times and I think I've
given you a number of reasons why the
growth package is going to be good for
jobs let me take an example of the
National Insurance people who are
struggling to pay their bills really the
National Insurance point last week saves
uh saves 30 million households about 300
pounds that's significant if you don't
think that's significant then I'm sad to
hear that the point is that what people
need is opportunities and the growth
package creates those that National
Insurance cut for businesses for example
will mean that actually 900 000
businesses across the country have
around 10 000 pounds extra in their
budgets now 900 000 000 businesses that
could be a thousand in Norwich where I
live that could be a thousand where in
where you live I don't know where you
live okay but around our country in
every single place there will be
thousands of businesses who are able to
create more jobs from the Chancellor's
package and I think that's really
important only 81 000 people voted to
make list trust the next our present
prime minister why does she feel that
she has a mandate to do this with our
tax affairs
because people at the last general
election voted conservative they voted
conservative in my constituency and up
and down the country and that enabled
conservatives as you know to form the
largest party in Parliament I don't mean
to give you a constitutional history
lesson but that is okay and their thanks
for explaining that has the right to be
prime minister and I'm really proud that
she is because she's being bold and
ambitious and will create more jobs in
this country yeah okay
um talk to me about Mark Fullbrook he's
the PM's new Chief of Staff
um why is his salary being paid by his
lobbying company
I think you will have the details of
what the cabinet office explained I do
on this point I don't have a great deal
more to add to that information that
you've got from the cabinet office I
believe there are um I believe there are
uh I believe I believe they've set out
the details for uh how his arrangement
stands I don't have more to add to it
but what I can say is that I think the
Prime Minister has been very clear about
the standards that she expects and that
she will uphold through this government
and I fully expect she will be clear on
that with uh her Chief of Staff how do
you feel about a lobbyist being a chief
of staff
personally
I have no emotion on the mat okay
why why do you think some people think
it's controversial
I have nothing more to add as I say than
to what the cabinet office said
yesterday about his Arrangements indeed
I mean you are here representing the
government this morning know any more
about his personal Arrangements but what
I do know is that the Prime Minister
will be expecting them to be correct of
course and that the processes have been
followed and therefore that's why I'm
comfortable on the matter okay
um we have been chatting to John Harding
here at Sky News he's one of the five
people released in a prisoner swap with
Russia last week he said he was tortured
he certainly looks as though he's
suffered at the hands of his Russian
captors
um obviously against the Geneva
Convention what we're going to do about
it
well I'm pleased that John and others um
will be in a better position and I wish
them well personally of course there is
going to be a great deal more to do to
face down Putin's aggression and I think
the government is trust indeed while she
was foreign secretary and now prime
minister has been absolutely clear that
we cannot allow Putin's aggression to go
unchecked that is why we have such a
broad-based response to what has been
going on in Ukraine and elsewhere in our
relationships with Russia okay so we
will be speaking to Russia directly
about what should what should happen as
far as breaking the rules of the Geneva
Convention are concerned
I'm absolutely sure that the foreign
secretary will be taking that very very
seriously and communicate communicating
in the normal way with Russia and
echoing the government's overall stance
that Putin's aggression cannot go on and
cannot be unchecked okay um why do you
think the conservatives are doing so
badly in the polls at the moment
the conservatives will be in a position
to explain to the British people that we
have got growth going in the economy so
I want to go back to what the chancellor
announced last Friday and to what is for
me the absolute priority in my
department which is jobs and I know that
this is what really really matters to
people because that is of course one of
the best ways to improve household
income and find opportunity for yourself
and for your children but the markets
don't like it and the voters don't like
that so why do you think you're on the
right course that is what will matter
most to people and indeed to voters and
I have every confidence that the kind of
uh the kind of support that the
conservatives were delighted to have in
2019 will continue to follow Elizabeth
truss and be uh and be able to have a
conservative government in the years to
come but if the markets don't like it
and the voters don't like it why do you
think you're on the right path
because it is the correct path it is the
right path so everybody's everybody's
actually stepping apart from the
government it is the right path to help
people into jobs I don't think you could
argue on that particular Point okay well
I think I can look at the markets look
at what you're doing in the polls do you
not want people to be in jobs how would
you argue that point it's not um do I do
the questions you do the answers look
what the markets are doing and look what
the voters are saying yes and what we're
doing is going to make a difference in
the medium and long term we're going to
be able to help people into jobs you've
seen in the chancellor statement how we
are going to be going into uh the list
of projects that will make the most
difference to growth in this country as
well as then ways that will help
households and as well as the things
that will make a difference in the
medium to long term that is why I say we
are on the right path here because all
of those things will help people with
greater opportunity and put our country
back on the right track I fully stand by
that and I have every confidence that
people also will benefit from those jobs
as well okay and if I may on the ship
you may I'm being wrapped I'm being told
you have to go but do go on feel free
the sheer politics of it is that I don't
think labor have a Clear Vision or path
either well we'll wait and see uh thank
you for being so robust as always much
appreciated